[Music]
next gen gaming is already here i've had
a fully functional xbox series x
for a few days at this point and i put
as much time as possible into using it
and so far i'm impressed
[Music]
there are certain aspects of the series
x that we can't talk about quite yet but
of those things that are on the table
we have performance with backwards
compatible xbox one games
the hardware design itself load times
and the quick resume
feature and right now i'm feeling that
the latter two are real game changers
but first let's start with the actual
gameplay experience
currently we don't have access to any
series x specific content but microsoft
has made a set of backwards compatible
xbox one games available
in these first few days i've played the
outer worlds halo 5 guardians
final fantasy xv yakuza 0 ori in the
will of the wisps
and bloodstain ritual of the night a
variety of games
all available through game pass these
have all been smooth gameplay
experiences
nothing too unexpected or drastically
different from the xbox one x
in terms of performance so far but i did
want to call out one standout example of
the series x providing a noticeable
boost
in final fantasy 15 i enabled light mode
in the enhancement options which is also
available on the one x
this prioritizes frame rate allowing for
up to 60 fps
on the 1x the game would often drop
below 60 fps
with the series x from what i can tell
the game ran at a consistent 60fps
the entire time boosts in performance
are on a case-by-case basis
games that use dynamic resolution to
keep smooth frame rates
will maintain higher resolutions if not
native 4k
by virtue of the beefier hardware
barring a future update from developers
some games such as the outer worlds are
locked at 30fps
but at least you won't be dropping
frames and in games that allow
higher frame rates such as final fantasy
15 with performance mode enabled
as i mentioned you'll notice games
consistently hitting that high mark with
the series x
i've been using the lg bx series 4k hdr
tv
with hdmi 2.1 which offers 120 hertz
refresh rate
meaning it can display up to 120 frames
per second
although games such as ori will get that
120 fps enhancement
the feature has not been implemented in
ori or anything else yet
on the topic of backwards compatibility
you'll be happy to know that first party
games will support cross gen multiplayer
i can confirm this from my time playing
halo 5 online
using the series x for third party games
it'll be up to developers to enable
cross gen multiplayer
now for one of the heavy hitting
features of the series x
short load times microsoft has been
flexing its velocity architecture and
ultra fast solid state drive but i got
to see it go to work first
hand the xbox series x loads games much
much faster
than the xbox one x and we tested this
out by recording load times
on four different games in going from
the game's title screen
to loading a save game we got the
following numbers
red dead redemption 2 took 2 minutes and
8 seconds on the xbox one x
but only 38 seconds on the series x
control went from 58 seconds on the 1x
to 10 seconds on the series x final
fantasy xv
took a minute and 11 seconds on the 1x
and just 13 seconds
on the series x and the outer worlds
went from 43 seconds
to 11 seconds these numbers indicate
that the series x
cuts down on initial load times by 70 to
80 percent of the time it takes
for the one x and that's significant
this extends to booting up games from
the xbox dashboard
and also reloading saves and this is for
existing games that weren't built with
the tech in mind
but are simply taking advantage of the
faster drive speeds
it's a snappy overall experience similar
to my pc with an nvme ssd
this means you'll be spending less time
waiting and more time
gaming now for something related to
short load times in the velocity
architecture
we have quick resume it's the all new
series x and series s
feature that lets you suspend the state
of your current game
to go into another one and another one
and another one
all without shutting down or rebooting
any of those games
i was able to keep six games
simultaneously suspended in quick resume
and hop between them to pick up right
where i left off
with a seventh one booted the first game
i queued up in the process had to be
relaunched
though there doesn't seem to be a
warning of another game state having to
close
but let's be honest having 6 games held
in quick resume
is more than enough just so you know
swapping between games takes about 5 to
8 seconds
depending on where you paused it and
well that's so much faster than having
to relaunch an entire game
when it was first announced i didn't
think much of quick resume until i
experienced it for myself
personally i like jumping between
different genres or styles of games when
i sit down for a gaming session
mixing things up when i've had my fill
and in conjunction with game pass
where i'm often jumping between multiple
games i have downloaded anyway
it really starts to shine quick resume
is a type of feature that we don't even
see on pc
and in that regard the xbox series x
showcases some
innovative next-gen tech it's kind of a
game changer
literally onto the hardware itself the
new controller offers some subtle but
noticeable improvements
over the current xbox controllers first
is the textured grip on the handles and
the triggers
and a bit on the bumpers it's a nice
tactile feel that's going to help
prevent slipping
especially for you sweaty folk the
dedicated share button is clutch too
letting you capture screenshots and
video clips on the fly which even works
if you connect it to an xbox one
the new 8-way d-pad is quite clicky and
a bit stiff
though it is responsive i personally
like it but it really comes down to
preference
now we all know that the xbox series x
has a thick brick like design
but it's not as big as you might think
it certainly towers over the other
current gen consoles in terms of height
whether you stand it up vertically or
lay it sideways either way you'll want
to make sure you have enough vertical
clearance in your setup for it
but i don't find its size and shape all
that prohibitive
there's still a lot more to explore with
the xbox series x
but that's all i can get into right now
since we've only had access to xbox one
backwards compatible games
we haven't really had the chance to see
the series x fully flex its graphical
horsepower quite yet
but we'll get there again i want to
reiterate how refreshing it was to have
such fast
snappy loading for console games and to
have quick resume changing the way i can
jump from one game to another
and get more out of my time playing i've
said this before but i feel like the
next gen experience will be impacted
more by those practical improvements in
the user experience
and that's what i've been most impressed
with in the series x so far
for more on the xbox series x be sure to
check out our full video
of the load time comparisons and with
quick resume in action
and for all your next gen news needs be
sure to stick to gamespot
because we have so much more coming
thanks for watching
[Music]